business icon ken Langone is on Forbes
magazine's list of the richest people in
the world but he insists he is not a
self-made success lingo and grew up in a
working-class family in Roslyn Heights
New York he first made a name for
himself on Wall Street as billionaire
Ross Perot's banker van Gogh and went on
to co-found one of America's largest
retailers Home Depot in 2008 after a 200
million dollar donation NYU Langone
Medical Center was renamed in his
family's honor and Goan wrote a memoir
about his unique path to success called
I love capitalism an American story ken
Langone welcome so great to have you
here it's a it's a great story of how
you got to being where you were as a kid
to now and I think one of the really
nice things you say in the beginning is
that you could fill Yankee Stadium with
all the people that helped you
absolutely it's not just a story about a
self-made I'm far from self-made with my
parents
humble uneducated great great capacity
for unconditional love I was kind of a
so-so kid and they get upset with me my
father used to say it any more than once
if I never see you again it'll be too
soon and that's a powerful incentive and
you had been approached many times to
write your life story in a book he
turned it down until the election of
2016 and he said you were motivated
because you saw a whole new generation
gravitate towards Bernie Sanders that
bothered you why if I hadn't even
started and they were quitting you know
well they have 21 22 years old give life
a shot take a few risks take some
chances if nobody should go to bed
hungry in America nobody in America
should not be educated and none of those
things but if we don't have kids
believing they can make a difference
that they do contribute something's
wrong
as a society something is wrong I don't
want anybody I should not this is the
insanity of
system I get a check every month in more
government what a disgrace
there are people out there that needed
that should get it not me
you draw a line between the private
sector and the government and where they
should stand and yes yeah I think the
more we can do for ourselves the better
we are remember there's somebody who
gets a check from the government and
does nothing for it you're taken away
from them in my opinion self-respect the
kid that gets his first job and has a
check holy smokes I did that you know
you build the success is built on but
but what the Sanders supporters would
say is you know that they talk about the
system being rigged and so they look at
Washington and they say you know the
president's lawyer is getting a lot of
money from companies who want influence
with the president so they see that
system and they say you know what we
need a real change in this system and
it's a system where you have 10 million
people who are in the working poor so
they're working hard they're not being
lazy and they still can't succeed in
America so they say something's got to
change okay Bernie author myself and Pat
fire has started home depot we have
400,000 associates working for the
company now full-time we have 80,000
seasonal in the spring in the fall we
have 3,000 kids that came to work for us
out of high school barely out of high
school pushing carts in from the parking
lot ready their multi-million yesterday
that's the capitalistic system the way
look are they do we do for everything
right absolutely not all I my fervent
belief is capitalism is the best way to
spread good things among a massive
number of people do capitalists need
then to Home Depot took the tax cut and
gave thousand dollar bonuses yes a lot
of companies didn't I think there was
one study and found about forty five of
the top 500 companies only gave those
kind of bonuses do capitalists then need
to be more like Home Depot look I'll
answer that question that's where the
biggest challenge to American my opinion
is income inequality if we don't fix
income inequality you will know what
happens Cuba happens finally
well happens Russia happens people that
are way down I was that on that end
bear in mind my parents on how to go to
work to work in a school cafeteria to
put food on the table we ate well and we
had a warm home we didn't have an
air-conditioned home but the point is
we've got to help these people but the
what best way out is to offer them
opportunities where they can develop not
only their own skills but their sense of
self-worth with when you take away from
me my sense of personal belief in myself
nothing's left but but should the should
people in your position in other
companies be doing more I guess is if
it's not to be done by government should
the cap Nora very nicely talked about
Yankee Stadium
I'm not self-made man there are a lot of
people out there who say they're
self-made that's for them to decide I'm
not home depot look at what we do for
veterans look at what we do for there's
a program at Home Depot cool and I'm
proud of let's call Ken's crew for
challenge Pete we have 400 of them in
the company now Down syndrome autism you
name it I can't tell somebody else
what's good for them if somebody wants
to say they're self-made that's a cool
my call is and first of all this goes on
everyone I look up grandma and grandpa
thanks for coming to America my
grandfather went to school until he was
six years old and that book there's a
picture of him and you look at his he
and it's know of why the man for 66
years from the time he was six years old
had a shovel and it's in don't look we
got a lot of things we did work on in
America but we're still the best place
on earth and we got to get better and
better and better can you have said
there will be no other America no other
they'll never be another American no no
great ancestor congratulations on the
book thank you for having me I really
appreciate it thank you so much that his
book I love capitalism and I marry
story is on sale wherever you like to
buy books